I think it's very important to consider
that youth participation and economic
development of Latin America is key the
youth are the new generation the
consumers of the future they should get
involved early on in their education so
explain to them how they will
participate actively not only in getting
to know the region but also in
developing their own capabilities to
then contribute back to the society I
think it's very important I think the
other participation which is key is also
to listen to the youth population in
Latin America and understand you know
their motivations their desires their
ambitions and work so that the
educational system and help them develop
into being more holistic human beings so
I hope this helps thanks a lot for
participating